NARRATOR: THE ELEPHANT.
THEIR EARS CAN BE OVER 1/6
THE SIZE OF THEIR ENTIRE BODY.
BUT YOU'RE ABOUT TO
FIND OUT HOW THEY CAN HEAR
WITH THEIR FEET.
LAWRENCE: THEY'RE JUST
SORT OF MIND BLOWING.
NARRATOR: PLUS, CATS!
THEY'RE THE MOST
POPULAR PET IN AMERICA.
BUT THEIR PURRS MAY HELP KEEP
ASTRONAUTS ALIVE IN SPACE.
NATALIA: CATS IN SPACE!
NARRATOR: AND THE OCTOPUS.
IT'S BEEN ON THE PLANET
FOR OVER 90 MILLION YEARS.
BUT CAN THIS CREATURE
FROM THE PAST ACTUALLY
PREDICT THE FUTURE?
ROGER: IF YOU PUT A HUMAN
IN AN OCTOPUS ENVIRONMENT,
IT WOULDN'T SURVIVE
EVEN A DAY PROBABLY.
NARRATOR: THIS IS WHERE
SAVAGE MEETS SCIENCE...
AND WILD BECOMES "WOW."
THIS IS, "EVERYTHING YOU
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT ANIMALS."
IT'S HEART ALONE WEIGHS MORE
THAN A FIVE YEAR OLD CHILD.
IF IT WERE STANDING
IN NEW YORK...
IT COULD HEAR A
RAINSTORM IN PHILLY.
JUST FOUR HOURS MOVING IN
THE HOT SUN COULD KILL IT...
IF NOT FOR A
SECRET IN ITS EARS.
IT'S STRONG ENOUGH TO
PUSH A TWO TON TRUCK...
AND SMART ENOUGH TO
PAINT A PICTURE...
IT IS THE ELEPHANT.
SOUTH AFRICA.
A BABY ELEPHANT HAS FALLEN
INTO A WATERING HOLE.
TRAGEDY COULD BE
CLOSE AT HAND.
BUT LOOK CAREFULLY...
SUDDENLY, THE COMMUNITY OF
ELEPHANTS RUSHES TO THE RESCUE;
IT'S NOW A GROUP EFFORT
TO GET THIS BABY TO SAFETY,
BUT HOW?
CAITLIN: YOU DON'T
SEE THEM SIGNALING.
THEY JUST KNOW.
THEY JUST GET IN THERE,
GET DOWN ON THEIR KNEES,
PULL THE BABY OUT.
ELEPHANTS ARE JUST AMAZING.
NARRATOR: NOT ONLY
ARE THEY AMAZING BUT
THEY'RE ALSO SMART...
THEY HAVE BEEN OBSERVED
DOING ADDITION WITH OVER 90%
ACCURACY AND KEEP TRACK
OF MORE THAN 30 FAMILY
MEMBERS AT ONCE.
IN FACT, IN A LOT OF WAYS,
ELEPHANT'S SEEM MORE
ADVANCED THAN US...
STARTING WITH THE LARGEST BRAIN
OF ANY LAND MAMMAL ALIVE...
IT'S UP TO 10 POUNDS
HEAVIER THAN OUR OWN.
BUT IT'S WHAT'S
INSIDE THAT COUNTS.
AN ELEPHANT'S TEMPORAL LOBES
TAKE UP 45% OF THEIR ENTIRE
BRAIN COMPARED TO OUR 20%.
THAT'S WHAT GIVES THEM
THEIR FAMOUS MEMORIES.
BUT THAT BIGGER TEMPORAL
LOBE ALSO HELPS THE ELEPHANT
PROCESS SOUNDS...
AND WHEN IT COMES TO HEARING,
THEY HAVE ABILITIES THAT WALK
ALL OVER OURS.
BECAUSE THEY CAN ACTUALLY
HEAR WITH THEIR FEET!
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS: ELEPHANTS
SOMETIMES COMMUNICATE WITH
EACH OTHER OVER LONG
DISTANCES BY STOMPING,
OR SENDING LOW FREQUENCY
RUMBLES THROUGH THE GROUND.
THESE SEISMIC WAVES THEN
TRAVEL THROUGH THE EARTH AND
GET PICKED UP BY VIBRATION
SENSITIVE CELLS IN AN
ELEPHANT'S FEET CALLED
"PACINIAN CORPSUCLES."
THEN, THOSE CELLS SEND A NERVE
IMPULSE STRAIGHT TO THE BRAIN.
CAITLIN: SO YOU'RE
NOT ACTUALLY HEARING
THROUGH YOUR EAR.
YOU'RE HEARING DIRECTLY TO
THE BRAIN THROUGH THESE NERVE
IMPULSES COMING FROM
THESE VIBRA-TACTILE CELLS.
NARRATOR: IN ADDITION TO
HELPING THE ELEPHANT KEEP
TRACK OF FAR-FLUNG
FAMILY MEMBERS...
THIS SEISMIC SENSITIVITY MAY
AID IN THE ELEPHANT'S SEARCH
FOR LIFE SUSTAINING WATER.
ONE STUDY ANALYZED DATA
FROM GPS TRACKING DEVICES OF
FOURTEEN DIFFERENT
HERDS OVER SEVEN YEARS.
THEIR FINDINGS SUGGEST THAT
ELEPHANTS CAN TELL WHEN A
STORM IS APPROACHING EVEN
IF IT'S 150 MILES AWAY!
CAITLIN: WE THINK THEY'RE
DETECTING THUNDER IN THE GROUND.
NARRATOR: YOUR LOCAL
WEATHERMAN COULD LEARN A
THING OR TWO.
AND THAT MAY NOT
BE SO FAR-FETCHED.
HUMANS HAVE THE SAME VIBRATION
SENSITIVE CELLS AS ELEPHANTS
IN OUR OWN HANDS AND FEET AND
HIGH-TECH HEARING AIDS ARE NOW
BEING DEVELOPED THAT UTILIZE
THEM IN THE SAME WAY THE
ELEPHANT DOES.
OF COURSE ELEPHANTS ALSO
USE THEIR FEET IN THE MORE
TRADITIONAL WAY.
AN AVERAGE AFRICAN ELEPHANT
CAN COVER 50 MILES A DAY.
THAT'S OVER 18,000
MILES A YEAR...
ROUGHLY SIX AND A HALF
TIMES THE DISTANCE FROM
NEW YORK TO CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU WERE TO RUN
THAT MUCH IN A YEAR,
YOU'D GO THROUGH UP TO
60 PAIRS OF SHOES...
IF YOUR LEGS DIDN'T
GIVE OUT FIRST.
BUT ELEPHANTS HAVE AN
EXTRA SUPPORT SYSTEM BUILT
RIGHT INTO THEIR FEET.
LAWRENCE: THEY ACTUALLY WALK
ON THE TIPS OF THEIR TOES.
BUT THEY SORT OF HAVE THIS
FAT FILLED HEEL THAT ACTUALLY
SUPPORTS THEIR WEIGHT.
NARRATOR: AND
INSIDE THAT FAT PAD?
IT'S THE ELEPHANT'S
OWN STILLETO HEEL...
A BACKWARD FACING SIXTH TOE
THAT HELPS KEEP THE ELEPHANT
FROM KEELING OVER DURING LONG
TREKS FOR WATER AND FOOD!
THIS EXTRA "TOE" FORMS AS A
SMALL ROD OF CARTILAGE THAT
GROWS LONGER AND STRONGER.
AS THE ELEPHANT AGES,
THE DIGIT EVENTUALLY
TRANSFORMS INTO BONE.
IT'S LIKE A KICKSTAND
BUILT RIGHT INTO THE FOOT.
AND WHO COULDN'T
USE ONE OF THOSE?
DISNEY DID A PRETTY GOOD JOB
OF MAKING ELEPHANT EARS FLY
BUT EVEN IN REAL LIFE,
THEY'RE PRETTY AMAZING.
IN FACT, THEY DO A LOT MORE
FOR THE ELEPHANT THAN OUR EARS
DO FOR US.
THEY MAY EVEN HELP
KEEP THEM ALIVE.
WHERE SOME ELEPHANTS LIVE,
TEMPERATURES CAN REACH A
SCORCHING HOT 122
DEGREES FAHRENHEIT.
BECAUSE OF THIS
FIERY ENVIRONMENT,
ELEPHANTS LIVE IN CONSTANT
DANGER OF OVERHEATING.
JUST FOUR HOURS OF MOVING
IN THE HOT SUN IS ENOUGH TO
DO AN ELEPHANT IN.
YOU MAY THINK THEY BEAT
THE HEAT BY ROLLING AROUND
IN THE MUD.
BUT THAT'S ONLY
PART OF THE STORY.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, ONE
OF THEIR MOST IMPORTANT
MECHANISMS FOR CHILLING OUT...
IS INSIDE THE EARS.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS:
THE SKIN ON AN ELEPHANT'S EAR
IS VERY THIN...
JUST ONE TO TWO MILLIMETERS.
BARELY THICKER THAN A PENNY.
LOOK EVEN CLOSER AND YOU'LL
SEE AN INTRICATE NETWORK OF
BLOOD VESSELS JUST
BELOW THE SURFACE.
WHEN AN ELEPHANT
FLAPS ITS EARS,
AIR FLOWS OVER THESE VESSELS,
COOLING THE BLOOD WITHIN.
THEN, LIKE FREON IN
AN AIR CONDITIONER,
THE COOLED BLOOD MOVES
THROUGH THE REST OF ITS
CIRCULATORY SYSTEM.
THAT REDUCES ITS CORE
TEMPERATURE BY AS MUCH
AS 10 DEGREES.
YOU MIGHT EVEN CALL THEM
EARS "EAR CONDITIONERS."
USING THEIR EARS,
AN ELEPHANT CAN COOL ALL THE
BLOOD IN THEIR BODY
IN JUST TWENTY MINUTES.
THE ELEPHANT IS THE ONLY
MAMMAL, BESIDES HUMANS,
THAT HAS A CHIN.
ITS FOOTPATHS ARE SO MASSIVE;
SATELLITES CAN
SEE THEM FROM SPACE.
IT IS THE LARGEST
ANIMAL ON LAND AND YET,
IF YOU WANTED TO CATCH A
GLIMPSE OF ANCIENT ELEPHANTS,
YOUR BEST BET
MIGHT'VE BEEN BY BOAT.
CAITLIN: ELEPHANTS HAVE AN
AQUATIC ANCESTRY AND WHEN YOU
SEE AN ELEPHANT IN
WATER, IT SEEMS OBVIOUS.
THEY CAN SWIM IN IT, THEY CAN
USE THEIR TRUNK AS A SNORKEL
AND THEY SWIM ACROSS THE
RIVER COMPLETELY SUBMERGED.
AND THEY'RE VERY
GOOD SWIMMERS.
NARRATOR: THEY MIGHT EVEN
SHARE A COMMON ANCESTOR WITH
THE ENTIRELY AQUATIC
MANATEE AND DUGONG.
BUT IT'S COME A LONG WAY SINCE
SWIMMING THE RIVERS OF THE
PAST AND AS WE'VE SEEN,
IT'S EVOLVED INTO A CREATURE
THAT IN SOME WAYS MAY
BE MORE ADVANCED THAN US.
BUT THERE IS ONE THING THAT
TERRIFIES THIS COMPLICATED
GIANT AND IT'S EVEN
SMALLER THAN A BASKETBALL.
IS IT: A,
A SKITTERING FIELD MOUSE?
B, A THORNY BRANCH?
OR C, A BUZZING BEE?
PLUS, FIND OUT WHY ROBOTICS
ENGINEERS ARE DROOLING OVER
THE ELEPHANT'S TRUNK!
NARRATOR: THE ELEPHANT, AN
ANIMAL AS ODD AS IT IS EPIC
BUT AS IMPRESSIVE AS THEY
ARE, THERE IS ONE THING THAT
TERRIFIES THE ELEPHANT
AND IT'S EVEN SMALLER
THAN A BASKETBALL.
IS IT: A,
A SKITTERING FIELD MOUSE?
B, A THORNY BRANCH?
OR C, A BUZZING BEE?
THE CORRECT ANSWER
IS "C," THE BEE.
AS GIANT AS THEY ARE, THE
ELEPHANT HAS NO DEFENSES
AGAINST TINY BEES GETTING
INSIDE THEIR SENSATIVE TRUNKS
AND STINGING.
AND WITH THEIR
MASSIVE MEMORIES,
THAT'S A STING
THEY NEVER FORGET.
ELEPHANTS ARE SO SCARED
OF GETTING STUNG,
FARMERS IN AFRICA ACTUALLY USE
FENCES MADE OF BEE HIVES TO
KEEP THE BEHEMOTHS FROM
DESTROYING THEIR CROPS.
SO THAT'S ONE WAY WE HAVE
A LEG UP ON DUMBO BUT THE
ELEPHANT ISN'T STOPPING YET.
AND WHEN IT COMES
TO SHOWING US UP,
NO PART OF THE ELEPHANT
DOES A BETTER JOB...
THAN A TRUNK WHICH
SMELLS AT LEAST 5,000 TIMES
BETTER THAN A HUMAN'S NOSE.
SCIENTISTS HAVE RECENTLY
DISCOVERED THAT THE ELEPHANT
HAS MORE SMELLING GENES
IN ITS TRUNK THAN ANY OTHER
CREATURE WE KNOW OF.
IT'S SENSE OF SMELL IS EVEN
FIVE TIMES GREATER THAN A
BLOODHOUND AND IT CAN DETECT
THE SMELL OF WATER FROM UP TO
TWELVE MILES AWAY.
OF COURSE, THE TRUNK IS SO
MUCH MORE THAN JUST A SNIFFER.
IT CAN TRUMPET 8 TIMES
LOUDER THAN A SUBWAY TRAIN...
IT CAN VACUUM UP ENOUGH WATER
IN ONE SHOT TO HYDRATE A MAN
FOR THREE DAYS...
AND LIFT OVER 600 POUNDS...
THAT'S MORE THAN THE WEIGHT
OF A FULL GROWN TIGER!
BUT HOW CAN ONE ORGAN GENERATE
SO MUCH MORE POWER AND
VERSATILITY THAN US
HUMANS CAN EVEN DREAM OF?
LET'S TAKE A CLOSER LOOK.
BENEATH THAT ONE INCH THICK,
PACHYDERM SKIN -THERE ARE OVER
100,000
SEPARATE MUSCLE GROUPS...
BUT ZERO BONES.
WHICH MAKES THE TRUNK
EXTREMELY FLEXIBLE.
IN HUMANS, MUSCLES CAN
ONLY CONTRACT AS FAR AS
THE BONES ALLOW.
BUT ELEPHANTS CAN
PRETTY MUCH BEND THEIR TRUNKS
IN ANY DIRECTION.
LAWRENCE: THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE SCIENTISTS CALL
A MUSCULAR HYDROSTAT.
AND WHAT WE MEAN
BY THAT IS THAT IT USES
HYDROSTATIC PRESSURE.
NARRATOR: THESE BONELESS
MUSCULAR HYDROSTATS APPEAR
ELSEWHERE IN NATURE...
FROM THE LOWLY WORM
TO AN OCTOPUS'S ARM...
BUT ONE OF THE BIGGEST AND
THE STRONGEST BY FAR IS THE
ELEPHANT'S TRUNK.
BUT DON'T BE JEALOUS.
YOU HAVE A MUSCULAR
HYDROSTAT TOO...
IT'S YOUR OWN TONGUE.
RESEARCHERS ARE SO IMPRESSED
WITH THE POWER AND FLEXIBILITY
OF ELEPHANT TRUNKS,
THEY'RE DEVELOPING ROBOTIC
ARMS BASED ON THEM.
IN THE SAME WAY THERE ARE NO
BONES IN AN ELEPHANT'S TRUNK,
THERE ARE NO METAL RODS
OR WIRES IN THIS ROBOT.
IT USES AIR PRESSURE
TO CHANGE ITS SHAPE,
JUST LIKE THE ELEPHANT
USES HYDROSTATIC PRESSURE.
THIS OPENS UP A WORLD
OF POSSIBILITIES,
INCLUDING MINIATURE FLEXIBLE
ROBOTS THAT COULD GO INSIDE
HUMAN BODIES FOR
PRECISION SURGERY.
SO THE NEXT TIME YOU FIND AN
ELEPHANT TRUNK INSIDE YOU,
IT MIGHT JUST BE TRYING
TO SAVE YOUR LIFE.
WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT ALL THE THINGS
ELEPHANTS CAN DO
THAT HUMANS CAN'T.
BUT MAYBE THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE THING ABOUT THIS
INTELLIGENT BEAST...
IS HOW MUCH LIKE US THEY ARE.
ON AN EMOTIONAL LEVEL, WE
MAY BE CLOSER THAN YOU THINK.
TODD: ELEPHANTS CAN
DIFFERENTIATE UP TO A HUNDRED
OR MORE DIFFERENT INDIVIDUALS
JUST BASED ON THE SOUNDS THAT
THEY MAKE AND THE SMELLS
THAT THEY GIVE OFF.
NARRATOR: AN ANIMAL
SANCTUARY IN TENNESSEE ACCEPTS
A SPECIAL DELIVERY...
A 51-YEAR-OLD ASIAN
ELEPHANT NAMED SHIRLEY.
BUT ANOTHER ELEPHANT,
NAMED JENNY,
IMMEDIATELY REACTS
TO SHIRLEY'S ARRIVAL.
THE TWO TRUMPET AND RUMBLE
THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT.
THEY EVEN BEND THE MASSIVE BARS
TRYING TO REACH EACH OTHER.
TODD: THE ELEPHANTS
SHIRLEY AND JENNY,
THEY HAD WORKED TOGETHER
EARLIER 23 YEARS AGO IN THE
CIRCUS AND NOT EVEN FOR A
VERY LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
THEY WERE RE INTRODUCED
TO EACH OTHER AND IT WAS
LIKE IT WAS YESTERDAY.
THEY INSTANTLY KNEW
WHO EACH OTHER WERE.
NARRATOR: SO MAYBE
IT REALLY IS TRUE THAT AN
ELEPHANT NEVER FORGETS...
AND WE HAVE TROUBLE
REMEMBERING TO CALL OUR MOMS.
THEY'RE THE MOST
POPULAR PET IN AMERICA.
BUT DID WE CHOOSE THEM?
OR DID THEY CHOOSE US?
IS THAT MEOW A SIMPLE "HELLO?"
OR A SECRET CALL DESIGNED
TO TRICK OUR MINDS.
CAN THEIR PURR ACTUALLY HELP
SEND ASTRONAUTS DEEPER INTO
SPACE THAN THEY'VE
EVER TRAVELLED BEFORE?
AND IS IT TRUE THAT A
PARASITE IN A CAT'S STOMACH CAN
SEND A WOMAN'S SEX
DRIVE THROUGH THE ROOF?
MIESHELLE: WOMEN WHO
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO IT ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE A LOT NICER
AND EVEN PROMISCUOUS.
[LAUGHS].
NARRATOR: THEY'VE
SURVIVED FALLS AS HIGH AS
THIRTY-TWO STORIES.
THEY CAN HEAR NOTES TWO
OCTAVES HIGHER THAN YOU.
AND ACCORDING TO
AT LEAST ONE STUDY,
15% OF ALL INTERNET TRAFFIC
IS CONNECTED TO THEIR ANTICS.
THEY'RE QUIRKY...
THEY'RE CRAFTY AND CONSIDERING
ALMOST ONE IN THREE AMERICAN
HOMES HAS ONE, THEY'RE
PROBABLY SITTING ON YOUR LAP
RIGHT NOW.
THEY'RE HOUSE CATS...
ONE OF THE WORLD'S
MOST POPULAR PETS.
BUT HOW EXACTLY DID THEY CLAW
THEIR WAY TO THE TOP SPOT?
MIKKEL: I THINK ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE LOVE CATS SO
MUCH IS THAT THEY
ARE VERY ADAPTABLE.
MARTY: YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WALK THE CAT, YOU KNOW?
YOU CAN PROVIDE
EXERCISE, THINGS INSIDE.
YOU CAN LEAVE IT OVERNIGHT
WITH SOME FOOD AND WATER.
THERE ARE CERTAIN ADVANTAGES
YOU JUST HAVE IN CATS.
MIESHELLE: AND THEY'RE REALLY
CUTE AND FUNNY, YOU KNOW?
AS SIMPLE AS THAT
MIGHT BE, IT'S TRUE.
NARRATOR: SORRY, ROVER.
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO
TELL YOU EVERYTHING ABOUT
CATS, WE'RE ABOUT TO UNCOVER
EIGHT OF THE MOST INTERESTING
FACTS YOU MIGHT NOT KNOW
ABOUT OUR FELINE FRIENDS.
STARTING WITH THIS: CATS
HAVE A TENDENCY TO HUNT MICE.
BUT THEY MAY ACTUALLY
BE FORCING SOME
BIRDS INTO EXTINCTION.
A 2010 UNIVERSITY OF NEBRASKA
STUDY REVEALED THAT CATS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE EXTINCTION
OF AT LEAST THIRTY-THREE
SPECIES OF BIRDS WORLDWIDE.
MARTY: WELL THE AUDUBON
SOCIETY HATES THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE OUT THERE BECAUSE
THEY ARE LETHAL KILLERS.
NARRATOR: OUTDOOR CATS
MAY EVEN BE KILLING UP TO
3.7 BILLION BIRDS IN THE
UNITED STATES EVERY YEAR.
THAT'S MORE THAN HALF
THE HUMAN POPULATION OF
THE ENTIRE WORLD...
EVERY YEAR!
IT'S A KITTY APOCALYPSE!
BUT WHILE THEY MIGHT SOMETIMES
SEEM LIKE LITTLE TIGERS...
CATS DO HAVE A SOFTER SIDE AND
WHETHER THEY'RE HAIRLESS OR
HAIRFUL, ALL
SMALL BREEDS PURR.
BUT WHY?
MARTY: YOU ALWAYS
ASSOCIATE PURRING, I THINK,
WITH HAPPY AND CONTENT.
AND SOMETIMES
IT'S THE OPPOSITE.
YOU'LL SEE CATS PURR WHEN
THEY'RE IN EXTREME PAIN.
YOU'LL ALSO SEE CATS PURRING
RIGHT BEFORE THEY DIE.
NARRATOR: AS IT TURNS OUT,
THAT PURR MAY BE MORE POWERFUL
THAN ANYONE EVER REALIZED.
THAT LEADS US TO OUR
AMAZING CAT FACT NUMBER TWO:
A CAT'S PURR MAY HAVE
HEALING PROPERTIES.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS:
WHEN CATS PURR,
THEY DO SO AT A RATE OF
25 VIBRATIONS PER SECOND.
MARTY: THAT 25 VIBRATIONS
PER SECOND IS A VERY, UH,
YOU KNOW, HEALING FREQUENCY.
NARRATOR: IT'S TRUE.
A RECENT UC DAVIS STUDY
REVEALED THAT VIBRATIONS AT
THAT RATE COULD IMPROVE BONE
DENSITY AND PROMOTE HEALING IN
ANIMALS AND IN HUMANS.
IF YOU CAN BELIEVE IT,
RESEARCHERS ARE EVEN LOOKING
AT HOW THE CAT'S PURR MAY ONE
DAY HELP SEND MEN TO MARS.
NATALIA: ASTRONAUTS GENERALLY
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH BONE
DENSITY LOSS AND ATROPHY
BECAUSE OF THE LONG PERIODS OF
TIME IN A SMALL SPACE.
SO SOME SCIENTISTS THINK THAT
IF YOU EXPOSE ASTRONAUTS TO
THE SAME FREQUENCY AS A PURR,
YOU CAN ACTUALLY IMPROVE
BONE DENSITY AND
DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF
ATROPHY IN ASTRONAUTS.
SO THIS TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY
MIGHT ALLOW ASTRONAUTS TO
TRAVEL DEEPER INTO SPACE.
NARRATOR: THERE IS A SAYING
THAT GOES "CATS WERE ONCE
WORSHIPPED AS GODS AND
THEY'VE NEVER FORGOTTEN."
THE SENTIMENT IS SPOT ON
BUT SO IS THE BACKSTORY.
AND THAT'S OUR CAT FACT
NUMBER THREE: CATS WERE ONCE
WORSHIPPED LIKE GODS.
IN FACT, 4,000 YEARS AGO,
EGYPTIANS HELD CATS IN SUCH
HIGH REGARD, THEY
ACTUALLY MUMMIFIED THEM,
ENSURING SAFE PASSAGE
INTO THE AFTERLIFE.
KILLING A CAT IN
EGYPT WAS EVEN CONSIDERED
A CAPITOL OFFENSE,
PUNISHABLE BY DEATH.
BUT WHEN A CAT
PASSED ON NATURALLY,
ANCIENT EGYPTIANS HAD A
STRANGE TRADITION AND IT GOES
WAY BEYOND ANYTHING
WE DO TODAY.
DID THE PEOPLE:
A, SHAVE THEIR
OWN EYEBROWS...
B, CARVE A FIGURINE,
OR C, STAY AWAKE
UNTIL SUNRISE?
PLUS, CAN A COMMON PARASITE
LIVING INSIDE CATS ACTUALLY
CONTROL THE MINDS OF HUMANS?
EVERYTHING ELSE YOU
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT CATS...
WHEN WE RETURN.
NARRATOR: CATS.
WITH NEARLY 600 MILLION
OF THEM WORLDWIDE,
THEY'RE ONE OF THE MOST
POPULAR PETS ON THE PLANET.
BUT HOW WELL DO WE REALLY
KNOW OUR FELINE FRIENDS?
BEFORE THE BREAK, WE ASKED
"HOW DID ANCIENT EGYPTIAN
FAMILIES MOURN THEIR
DECEASED FELINES?"
DID THE PEOPLE:
A, SHAVE THEIR
OWN EYEBROWS...
B, CARVE A FIGURINE,
OR C, STAY AWAKE
UNTIL SUNRISE?
GIVE UP?
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, ACCORDING
TO THE ANCIENT HISTORIAN
HERODOTUS, WHEN EGYPTIAN CATS
PASSED ON TO THE AFTERLIFE,
THE ENTIRE HOUSEHOLD
WOULD OFTEN SHAVE THEIR
EYEBROWS IN MOURNING.
THAT'S KITTY COMMITMENT.
NOW, WE GET BACK
INTO OUR EIGHT,
LESSER-KNOWN FACTS ABOUT
THE CAT ON YOUR LAP.
FOR CAT FACT FOUR, WE'RE
TAKING THINGS UP A NOTCH...
OVER 300 FEET UP TO BE EXACT.
INCREDIBLY, CATS HAVE BEEN
KNOWN TO SURVIVE FALLS FROM AS
HIGH UP AS THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY.
BUT HOW?
MIKKEL: CATS DO NOT ALWAYS
LAND ON THEIR FEET BUT
THEY DO HAVE PRETTY AMAZING
KIND OF NINJA SKILLS
WHEN THEY'RE FALLING.
NARRATOR: TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THIS WORKS,
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
THE BACKBONE OF THE CAT.
CATS HAVE 30 VERTEBRAE
IN THEIR SPINES,
COMPARED TO OUR 24.
THEY CAN BEND ALMOST
A FULL 180 DEGREES,
WHICH ALLOWS CATS TO ROTATE
AND RIGHT THEIR HEADS IN THE
AIR, THEN QUICKLY TWIST THE
REST OF THEIR BODIES AROUND.
AT THE SAME TIME, THE
FALLING CAT ARCHES ITS BACK,
WHICH DAMPENS THE FORCE OF
IMPACT AS IT HITS THE GROUND.
CATS CAN MANIPULATE THEIR
BODIES TO LAND WITH A FORCE
FIVE TIMES LESS THAN AN
INANIMATE OBJECT DROPPED FROM
THE SAME HEIGHT.
AMAZINGLY ENOUGH, THE WAY A
CAT FALLS MAY INFLUENCE THE
FUTURE OF FIRST AID.
RESEARCHERS AT GEORGIA TECH
ARE ACTUALLY STUDYING
THE DYNAMICS OF FALLING
CATS' FLEXIBLE SPINES
TO CREATE UNBREAKABLE,
SELF-RIGHTING ROBOTS FOR SEARCH
AND RESCUE MISSIONS.
SO IN A WAY, CATS ARE TAKING
SOME OF THEIR NINE LIVES AND
GIVING THEM TO US.
BUT THERE'S MUCH MORE TO
A CAT THAN HOW IT FALLS.
FOR CAT FACT NUMBER FIVE, WE
EXPLORE THEIR "SUPER SENSES."
IT STARTS WITH THE EYES.
DOMESTIC CATS NEED JUST
ONE-SIXTH THE LIGHT THAT
HUMANS NEED TO SEE.
SO WHEN WE SEE BLACKNESS...
THEY SEE EVERYTHING.
CATS ALSO HAVE
EXCELLENT HEARING.
BETTER THAN DOGS, EVEN.
THEY'RE CAPABLE OF HEARING
FREQUENCIES UP TO 85,000 HERTZ.
PERFECT FOR SENSING
SMALL THINGS OF BIG INTEREST.
BUT IN ADDITION
TO NIGHT VISION GOGGLES AND
SUPER SONIC EARS...
CATS ALSO HAVE
POWERFUL NOSES...
14 TIMES STRONGER
THAN OUR OWN.
AND THEY USE THOSE NOSES TO
SNIFF OUT ONE OF THEIR MOST
FAVORITE THINGS.
SOME CATS FALL INTO A
TRANCE WHEN THEY SMELL IT.
OTHERS GO CRAZY WITH DELIGHT.
IT'S STRONG.
IT'S EFFECTIVE.
IT'S CATNIP.
THOUGH IT SEEMS LIKE
SOME EXOTIC NARCOTIC,
CATNIP IS JUST AN HERB
IN THE MINT FAMILY.
MIKKEL: SOME CATS ARE NOT
AFFECTED BY IT AT ALL.
BUT OTHER CATS, IT MAKES JUST
THIS GINORMOUS IMPACT ON THEM.
IT MAY BE LIKE KIND OF
MEOWY-WOWY FOR THEM WHERE
THEY'RE LIKE, "OH MAN,
THIS IS LIKE THE BEST."
NARRATOR: BUT
HOW DOES IT WORK?
THERE IS A CHEMICAL IN CATNIP
CALLED NEPETALACTONE THAT SOME
RESEARCHERS SPECULATE
MIMICS CAT PHEROMONES.
AND IT EVEN WORKS ON BIG CATS.
MARTY: SOME CATS GO MILD
AND SOME CATS GO WILD.
SOME ARE SCREECHING,
RUNNING AROUND,
THEY'RE EVEN FLYING
UP IN THE AIR,
GRABBING IMAGINARY THINGS.
AND OTHERS JUST SIT
THERE AND SLOBBER.
NARRATOR: BUT THE MOST
AMAZING THING ABOUT CATNIP MAY
BE THAT IT'S
NOT JUST FOR CATS.
HUMANS CAN USE IT TOO!
AND THAT'S OUR SIXTH
AMAZING CAT FACT.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
CATNIP MAKES AN EXCELLENT
MOSQUITO REPELLENT.
ACCORDING TO SOME STUDIES,
IT'S ACTUALLY 10 TIMES MORE
POWERFUL THAN DEET.
SO USE A LITTLE CATNIP
AND LOSE THE MOSQUITOS.
YOU MAY, HOWEVER,
BE SWARMED BY CATS.
THERE'S AN OLD ENGLISH
PROVERB THAT STATES,
"IN A CAT'S EYE,
ALL THINGS BELONG TO CATS."
AND THAT MAY INCLUDE US!
WHICH MAY EXPLAIN OUR
AMAZING FACT NUMBER SEVEN:
OLDER CATS ONLY
MEOW FOR HUMANS.
WHILE KITTENS WILL MEOW TO
LET THEIR MOM'S KNOW THEY'RE
HUNGRY, ONCE THEY GROW UP,
THAT MEOW IS ALL FOR US.
SOME CATS EVEN A HAVE A
SPECIFIC "HUNGER" CRY THAT WE
MAY BE HARDWIRED
TO RESPOND TO.
MIKKEL: IT'S BOTH A MEOW
AND A PURR TOGETHER.
SO IT'S LIKE THIS REALLY
COMPLEX NOISE THAT MIMICS
A BABY'S CRY.
SO IT MAKES US FEEL LIKE,
"OH MY GOSH, I CAN'T STAND IT.
I NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT."
NARRATOR: BUT THAT'S ONLY
SCRATCHING THE SURFACE OF HOW
YOUR CAT MAY BE
CONTROLLING YOU.
GET READY FOR THE EIGHTH
AND FINAL AMAZING CAT FACT:
YOUR CAT MIGHT ACTUALLY
BE ALTERING YOUR BRIAN!
SAY HELLO TO
TOXOPLASMA GONDII...
A MIND CONTROL PARASITE THAT
STARTS OUT IN SOME MICE.
NORMALLY, WHEN A MOUSE SMELLS
A CAT, IT RUNS THE OTHER WAY.
BUT MICE WITH THIS
PARASITE ARE ATTRACTED TO
THE SMELL OF CATS.
PROBLEM IS, WHEN CATS EAT THE
MICE, THEY GET THE BUG TOO...
THEN PASS IT ONTO US THROUGH
LITTER BOXES OR INFECTED SOIL.
SO WHAT DOES IT
DO TO INFECTED HUMANS?
DELAYED REACTION TIMES.
A TENDENCY TO GET
IN AUTO ACCIDENTS.
SLOPPINESS IN MEN...
NEATNESS IN WOMEN...
MARTY: YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
SOME RESEARCH OUT TO SUGGEST
THAT SOME PEOPLE COULD
HAVE SCHIZOPHRENIA AND OTHER
CONDITIONS FROM BEING
EXPOSED TO TOXOPLASMOSIS.
NARRATOR: IT SOUNDS LIKE IT
BELONGS IN A SCI-FI MOVIE...
UNTIL YOU HEAR THAT BETWEEN
30 AND 50% OF ALL
HUMANS ON EARTH CARRY
A TOXOPLASMA INFECTION.
MIEHSHELLE: I'VE BEEN
TESTED FOR IT AND I'VE BEEN
EXPOSED TO IT.
SO WOMEN WHO'VE BEEN
EXPOSED TO IT ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE A LOT NICER
AND EVEN PROMISCUOUS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH THAT IS TRUE.
NARRATOR: IT'S LIKE
A FELINE INVASION OF
THE BODY SNATCHERS!
SO MAYBE THAT'S
THE REAL REASON CATS ARE
THE MOST POPULAR PET.
THEY'RE CONTROLLING
OUR BRAINS.
THANKS A LOT, SHEEBA!
IT CREATES GHOSTS WITH ITS INK
AND CAN TASTE WITH ITS BODY.
SEVER ONE OF ITS LIMBS AND IT
WILL KEEP MOVING LIKE A SNAKE.
IT CAN COMPLETELY CHANGE SHAPE
IN THREE-TENTHS OF A SECOND.
AND SOME PEOPLE
EVEN BELIEVE...
IT CAN PREDICT THE FUTURE.
THE OCTOPUS...
IS NEXT.
NARRATOR: IT PUMPS
BLOOD USING THREE HEARTS,
IT CAN TASTE WITH THE
POWER OF 1600 TONGUES.
IF THEIR LIMBS
GET RIPPED OFF,
THEY CAN START TO
REGROW IN AS LITTLE
AS THREE DAYS...
SOME PEOPLE HAVE EVEN
SUGGESTED THEY MAY BE PSYCHIC.
ALL THIS FROM AN ANIMAL
THAT ONLY LIVES FOR ABOUT A
YEAR OR TWO...
IT'S THE OCTOPUS...
ONE OF THE MOST
CUNNING SURVIVALISTS.
BENEATH THE OCEAN'S SURFACE,
THE OCTOPUS IS CONSTANTLY
ON THE RUN.
ROGER HANLON: I CAN GLIBLY
DESCRIBE AN OCTOPUS AS A YUMMY
HUNK OF PROTEIN SWIMMING
IN THE OCEAN THAT EVERYTHING
IS TRYING TO EAT.
NARRATOR: SO THE OCTOPUS
MUST EMPLOY SOME TRULY UNIQUE
SKILLS TO STAY ALIVE.
NOW, WE'RE BREAKING DOWN
ALL THE INCREDIBLE WAYS IT
AVOIDS BEING LUNCH.
THE FIRST AND ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT OF ITS TOOLS
IS ITS AMAZING ABILITY...
TO CAMOUFLAGE.
NATALIA: THESE OCTOPUSES,
THEY'RE JUST CONSTANTLY,
YOU KNOW, CHANGING,
ADAPTING TO BECOME A STEALTHY
NINJA OF THE SEA.
NARRATOR: JUST
THREE-TENTHS OF A SECOND...
IS ALL IT TAKES.
IN THAT TIME, THE OCTOPUS
CAN COMPLETELY CHANGE
ITS COLOR AND PATTERN.
ROGER: WE CALL THIS RAPID
ADAPTIVE COLORATION.
THE ICONIC ANIMAL THE GENERAL
PUBLIC THINKS ABOUT FOR
CHANGING COLOR AND
PATTERN IS THE CHAMELEON.
BUT THEY HAVE A SLOW CHANGE
AND A LIMITED REPERTOIRE.
THE KING OF COLOR CHANGE
IS REALLY THE OCTOPUS.
NARRATOR: THE SECRET TO AN
OCTOPUS'S QUICK COLOR CHANGE
IS HIDDEN JUST UNDER
THE SURFACE OF THE SKIN.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
AT REST, AN OCTOPUSES
SKIN COLOR IS
USUALLY PRETTY UNIFORM.
BUT JUST BELOW THE SKIN
ARE TINY ELASTIC BAG-LIKE
STRUCTURES FILLED WITH
DIFFERENT COLORED PIGMENTS.
THEY'RE CALLED
"CHROMATOPHORES."
EACH OF THESE
CHROMATOPHORES IS SURROUNDED
BY MUSCLE FIBERS.
WHEN THEY CONTRACT,
THEY OPEN UP THE BAG AND
REVEAL A NEW COLOR.
AND WHEN THE MUSCLES RELAX,
IT SNAPS BACK IN AND
HIDES THE COLOR.
BUT HOW CAN THE OCTOPUS
CREATE SUCH AN AMAZING ARRAY
OF COLORFUL
PATTERNS SO QUICKLY?
ROGER: TO LOOK LIKE
600 OR 1,000 KINDS OF PLANTS
AND ANIMALS
WITHIN A THIRD OF A SECOND
IS TOTAL NONSENSE.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE,
YOU CAN'T DO IT.
THERE HAS TO BE A SHORT CUT.
NARRATOR: HERE'S THE SHORTCUT:
THE OCTOPUS HAS FIGURED OUT
THAT THERE ARE REALLY ONLY A
FEW BASIC PATTERNS IT NEEDS TO
KNOW TO BLEND INTO THE
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
UNIFORM, LIKE WHAT
YOU MIGHT SEE ON A ROCK
WITH NO CONTRAST...
MOTTLED, LIKE THE GRAVELLY
SUBSTRATE OF THE OCEAN FLOOR
AND DISRUPTIVE, WHICH MAKES
THE OCTOPUS UNRECOGNIZABLE IN
SHADOWY REEFS.
SO INSTEAD OF HAVING TO
INSTANTLY MATCH EVERY LITTLE
PIECE OF ITS ENVIRONMENT,
ALL THE OCTOPUS NEEDS IS A
QUICK VISUAL CUE TO TURN ON
ONE OF THE 3 PATTERNS
AND THEN FINE TUNE.
ROGER: SO ALL THEY HAVE
TO REALLY DO, IS SETTLE,
LOOK AROUND THEM, IF THE CUE
AROUND THEM IS FOR PATTERN 2,
THEY PUT ON PATTERN 2.
NARRATOR: IT'S LIKE BEING
ABLE TO INSTANTLY CHANGE YOUR
OUTFIT TO MATCH ANY OCCASION.
IT'S A COMPLEX SURVIVAL
TECHNIQUE FOR SURE.
BUT THE OCTOPUSES NEXT
SKILL TO STAY ALIVE MAY BE
EVEN MORE AMAZING....
WATCH THIS OCTOPUS
ONE MORE TIME.
NOTICE HOW IT'S NOT JUST HIS
COLOR AND PATTERN THAT CHANGES.
BUT ALSO... HIS TEXTURE.
A BIOLOGICAL STRUCTURE UNDER
THE SKIN ALLOWS THE OCTOPUS
TO MORPH IN 3-D.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS: RINGS
OF MUSCLES ON THE OCTOPUS'S
SKIN CONTRACT,
SQUEEZING IT INTO LUMPS.
INSIDE THE LUMPS, ANOTHER
SET OF MUSCLES TIGHTEN UP,
PULLING THE BLOBS OF
SKIN INTO DEFINED SHAPES.
WHEN THE OCTOPUS
WANTS TO SMOOTH OUT,
A THIRD GROUP OF MUSCLES
PULLS THE SKIN FLAT AGAIN.
ROGER: THERE'S NO OTHER
ANIMAL ON EARTH THAT CAN CHANGE
THE THREE DIMENSIONALITY
OF THEIR SKIN.
SO YOU EITHER GOT
IT OR YOU DON'T.
NARRATOR: THE OCTOPUS'S
ANCESTORS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
SURVIVE IN THE OCEAN FOR
UP TO 500 MILLION YEARS.
THAT'S OLDER THAN FISH!
BACK THEN, IT MIGHT HAVE HAD
EXTRA PROTECTION IN THE FORM
OF A HARD OUTER SHELL.
LIKE THE NAUTILUS OF TODAY.
BUT SOMEWHERE ALONG THE WAY,
THE OCTOPUS TRADED ITS ARMOR
FOR MORE ADVANCED
SURVIVAL TECHNIQUES...
WHICH ISN'T TO SAY THEY
WON'T BORROW SOMEBODY ELSE'S
SHELL IN A PINCH.
NATALIA: I JUST LIKE THE
IDEA THAT THEY COULD JUST BE
WEARING THE CLAM,
LIKE AS IF THAT IS GOING TO
MASK THEM COMPLETELY.
"NOTHING TO SEE HERE FOLKS."
♪ DOO, DEE, DOO,
DEE, DOO, DOO, ♪
DEE, DOO, DEE, DOO. ♪♪
[LAUGHS].
NARRATOR: SO FAR WE'VE BROKEN
DOWN THE OCTOPUS'S ABILITY
TO CHANGE COLOR AND SHAPE
IN ORDER TO STAY ALIVE.
BUT THERE'S ONE SPECIES IN
PARTICULAR THAT'S EVOLVED INTO
SUCH A SKILLED CREATURE,
IT STANDS OUT IN
THE OCTOPUS FAMILY...
THE MIMIC OCTOPUS.
IT CAN IMITATE A POISONOUS
LIONFISH OR LIKE THIS BROWN
MIMIC, BURY ALL BUT TWO OF
ITS ARMS TO LOOK LIKE A HIGHLY
VENOMOUS SEA SNAKE.
HERE, IT MIMICS A FISH
CALLED A BANDED SOLE...
A POISONOUS RELATIVE
OF THE FLOUNDER.
AND IN EACH OF THESE CASES, IT
NOT ONLY COPIES THE APPEARANCE
BUT THE SWIMMING STYLE AND
SPEED OF ITS INSPIRATION.
NO DISCUSSION OF THE OCTOPUS
IS COMPLETE WITHOUT MENTIONING
ITS MOST ICONIC APPENDAGES.
YOU KNOW IT HAS EIGHT
OF THEM BUT DO YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE CALLED?
ARE THEY A, ARMS?
B, LEGS?
OR C, TENTACLES?
PLUS, DOES THIS OCTOPUS
HAVE THE PSYCHIC SKILLS TO
BEAT THE VEGAS ODDS?
NARRATOR: THE OCTOPUS...
AN ALIEN WITH EIGHT
FAMOUS APPENDAGES.
BUT ARE THEY ARMS,
LEGS, OR TENTACLES?
THE ANSWER?
AN OCTOPUS'S APPENDAGES
ARE ACTUALLY CALLED "ARMS,"
BECAUSE THEY HAVE SUCKERS
ALL DOWN THEIR LENGTH.
IF THEY WERE TENTACLES,
THEY WOULD ONLY HAVE THEM
ON THEIR TIPS.
JUST ASK ANY SQUID,
WHICH HAVE TENTACLES.
SO OCTOPUSES HAVE EIGHT ARMS
AND ZERO TENTACLES, OR LEGS.
WHICH IS NOT TO SAY THEY
CAN'T USE THOSE ARMS LIKE WE
USE OUR LEGS.
NOW, WE GET BACK TO OUR
BREAKDOWN OF THE OCTOPUS'S
MOST ESSENTIAL
SURVIVAL TOOLS...
AND 8 OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT OF THOSE TOOLS ARE
THOSE ARMS WE WERE
JUST TALKING ABOUT.
THE GIANT PACIFIC OCTOPUS
CAN KEEP A PREDATOR AWAY
WITH AN ARM SPAN
OF UP TO 20 FEET...
THAT'S AS HIGH AS A
TWO STORY BUILDING.
BUT WHAT REALLY ALLOWS
THESE ARMS TO BE SUCH
LIFE SAVING TOOLS?
HUNDREDS OF
INDEPENDENTLY CONTROLLED,
MUSCULAR SUCTION CUPS.
FOR THE GIANT PACIFIC OCTOPUS,
EACH INDIVIDUAL SUCKER CAN
LIFT UP TO 35 POUNDS.
IF YOU ADD IT ALL UP,
THAT'S THEORETICALLY ALMOST
10,000 POUNDS OF
LIFTING-POWER PER ARM...
THE WEIGHT OF A MOVING TRUCK.
BUT THESE SUCTIONS CUPS
AREN'T JUST STRONG...
THEY'RE ALSO "SMART."
ROGER: SO MOST PEOPLE THINK
SUCKERS ARE TO GRAB AND HOLD
THINGS BUT IT'S
MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
SUCKERS ARE A VERY
SOPHISTICATED ORGAN.
NARRATOR: LET'S TAKE
A CLOSER LOOK INSIDE THE
SUCTION CUPS OF AN OCTOPUS.
EACH SUCKER IS COVERED IN
SENSITIVE CHEMICAL RECEPTORS
THAT HELP THE OCTOPUS
SENSE THE WORLD AROUND IT,
INCLUDING FOOD.
YES, THE OCTOPUS CAN
TASTE WITH EACH SUCKER.
EACH SUCTION CUP IS LIKE A
TONGUE AND WITH MANY SPECIES
HAVING OVER 200
SUCTION CUPS PER ARM...
THAT'S LIKE EACH OCTOPUS
HAVING OVER 1,600 TONGUES.
SO HOW CAN THE OCTOPUS'S
BRAIN PROCESS THE SIGNALS FROM
1,600 TONGUES, PLUS
EVERYTHING ELSE IT HAS TO DO,
ALL AT ONCE?
THE ANSWER?
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO.
THAT'S BECAUSE THEIR
ARMS DO MUCH OF THE WORK.
EACH OCTOPUS ARM HAS
THREE TIMES AS MANY NEURONS
THAN IN THEIR BRAIN.
IF YOU WERE TO
SEVER THE ARM,
THEN TOUCH A
PIECE OF FOOD TO IT,
THE SEVERED ARM WILL STILL
MOVE THE FOOD TO WHERE THE
MOUTH USED TO BE, EVEN
THOUGH THE HEAD ISN'T THERE...
AND EVEN AN HOUR AFTER
THE ARM'S BEEN SEVERED!
AND THAT'S NOT EVEN CLOSE
TO THE CRAZIEST ONE OF THE
OCTOPUS'S SURVIVAL SKILLS.
EVEN THOUGH THE OCTOPUS CAN
PERFECTLY MATCH THE COLOR OF
THEIR ENVIRONMENT, THEY
CAN'T ACTUALLY SEE COLOR.
THEY'RE COLOR BLIND.
NATALIA: ALL THIS COLOR
CHANGING AND SHAPE SHIFTING
AND THEY'RE COLORBLIND.
IT'S CRAZY...
THESE OCTOPUS, YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE BORN GENIUSES.
NARRATOR: SO HOW
DO THEY DO IT?
NEW EVIDENCE SUGGESTS
OCTOPUSES MAY BE DETECTING
COLORS THROUGH THEIR SKIN.
IT'S LIKE THEY'RE SEEING
WITH THEIR ENTIRE BODY.
ROGER: LIGHT DETECTING
MOLECULES IN OTHER ANIMALS
HAVE NEVER BEEN DEMONSTRATED.
IF WE CAN SOMEHOW FIND THAT
THEY HAVE THIS LIGHT SENSING
CAPABILITY TO DO SOMETHING
WITH IT THROUGHOUT THE SKIN,
IT WOULD BE REALLY
NEW TO SCIENCE.
NARRATOR: SO THE OCTOPUS
IS STILL TEACHING SCIENCE
SOMETHING NEW EVERY DAY.
BUT ITS MOST WELL KNOWN
SURVIVAL TOOL IS ITS ABILITY
TO DISAPPEAR INTO
A PUFF OF INK.
THERE MAY BE MORE GOING
ON IN THAT CLOUD THAN
ANYONE EVER REALIZED.
ROGER: PEOPLE SEE A
PUFF OF INK AND THEY SAY,
"OH, THAT'S COOL.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS."
BUT, THERE'S MUCH
MORE TO IT THAN THAT.
NARRATOR: SOME OCTOPUS INK
CONTAINS A CHEMICAL CALLED
TYROSINASE WHICH CAN DISRUPTS
AND CONFUSE A PREDATOR'S
SENSES LIKE SMELL AND TASTE.
AT THE SAME TIME, SOME
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE INK
MAY ALSO CONTAIN
NEUROTRANSMITTERS WHICH ALERT
OTHER OCTOPUSES THAT THERE'S
A PREDATOR IN THE AREA.
SO ITS NOT JUST SAVING ITSELF
BUT THE SPECIES AS A WHOLE AND
IT GETS MORE AMAZING.
BILL: THEY CAN EXPEL THE
INK IN THE FORM OF SOMETHING
CALLED A "PSEUDO-MORPH."
NARRATOR: HERE'S HOW IT WORKS:
SOMETIMES A FLEEING OCTOPUS
WILL SHOOT OUT A SMALL
BALL OF MUCUS WITH THE INK.
THIS MUCUS SURROUNDS
THE INK FORMING A DARK,
FLOATING SHAPE, OR
"PSEUDO-MORPH" THAT ACTUALLY
RESEMBLES ANOTHER
OCTOPUS THE EFFECT?
A GOOEY GHOST LEFT
HANGING IN THE WATER TO
CONFUSE HUNGRY FISH.
IT TAKES SOME PRETTY SPECIAL
BIOLOGY AND AN EVEN MORE
ADVANCED BRAIN TO PULL OFF
ALL THESE AMAZING ABILITIES.
HOW ADVANCED?
BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
SOME PEOPLE THINK THIS OCEANIC
ALIEN MAY EVEN BE PSYCHIC.
MEET PAUL THE OCTOPUS.
IT SEEMED PAUL HAD A KNACK
FOR PREDICTING THE FUTURE...
OR AT LEAST THE FUTURE FOR
THE GERMAN SOCCER TEAM.
PAUL'S KEEPERS WOULD
OFFER HIM TWO BOXES,
EACH WITH FOOD IN IT
AND EACH BEARING THE FLAG OF
A TEAM IN THE
UPCOMING SOCCER GAME.
WHICHEVER ONE PAUL OPENED
WAS CONSIDERED HIS PREDICTION.
IT SOUNDS PRETTY
RIDICULOUS UNTIL YOU HEAR
HE CHOSE THE WINNERS IN
ALL SEVEN OF GERMANY'S
2010 WORLD CUP MATCHES.
IF PAUL'S HANDLERS HAD PLAYED
THE ODDS AND PUT $1,000 DOWN
TO PICK ALL THE WINNERS,
PAUL WOULD'VE NETTED
A COOL $300,000.
AND FOR THIS
ULTIMATE SURVIVOR...
THAT'S "NEVER HAVING TO WORRY
ABOUT PREDATORS AGAIN" MONEY.